young lefty shane mcclanahan making his
sixth start of the season the era just
over four more than a strikeout at
inning to go up against just seven walks
an average fastball 97.4
and we have seen him on numerous
occasions hit triple digits with the two
there's a line drive and that's a base
hit to left so salvia is on and the
royals have their first hit mcclanahan
gets a new baseball
and there's a swing in the midst of the
high fastball at 98 and ben and tendy
is retired mcclanahan just the harmless
single to salvador perez at the end of
half an inning it's kansas city nothing
in the race on the way against brady
singer young righty brady singer making
his 10th start of the season his last
two starts he has pitched into the
seventh inning his pitcher well
and primarily the sinker the slider and
when i say primarily you add the usage
up and it's at about 95 percent
miss
slider there on that 2-2 well that
that's it that that that's his uh that's
his game two minute on for austin
meadows meadows is over six with a
couple of walks in the first two games
that's either into right center field
that'll give them an opportunity to run
wow will score hitting third choi
they're going to send him home the throw
will be cut off
in the third goes meadows and the rays
lead to nothing
and a ground ball to short
their throw to the plate it's not good
and the rays come up with another run
it's a swing and a drive high in the air
left center field back to his right
michael a taylor shy of the track rough
first inning for brady singer as he
gives up three it's three nothing tampa
bay going to the second
to see the shortstop three for eight
just returning to action
[Applause]
the first to complete the strikeout
second strikeout for mcclanahan he got
ben in tindy
on the fastball up at 98 to end the
first and now monday
and the pitch check swing strength three
cold make it over 18. mclanahan threw
him the slider he was in the zone
and down go the royals a nice shutdown
inning one going and now is kevin
carmeyer it's hard to win big league
ball games especially when you give
teams base runners that's a good pitch
there that's singer's second strikeout
and now he cracks one towards the right
side of the field by
merrifield who twirls and throws him out
so three up three down good comeback
inning for singer
there's a bunt by taylor and mcclanahan
tried to scoop with his glove
and taylor's on to begin the third
what
an excellent idea now the one-two again
swinging the ground while the short
could be two walls has it flips the
second out loud turns the first in time
for the double play
you couldn't have rolled it out there
any better it goes six to four to three
and just like that there's two gone
there's the first pitch to field and he
lines one toward the gap in right center
on the run is fellas he had to stop
reach back and make the catch
and oh my gosh he's he's smiling
i don't know if he lost in the lights or
what but a line drive to right and
phillips was able to make the grab now
with two ounces in the runner at second
base here is meadows
now the 01.
breaking ball lifted in the air to right
field
backing up but it is solaire to the wall
it is gone
boston meadows are the one-man wrecking
crew so far this afternoon his two-run
shot gives the rays a five-nothing lead
here in the third the infield back to
pitch dwindle swing and a high fly ball
left center field taylor going back at
the track to the wall jumps up he can't
get it it's off the wall backed up by
ben and tendy wendell on his way to
second takes the turn there and he'll
stop there
with a two out double
wendell will take his lead at second
base the infield back all the
way drive base hit through the right
side
wendell's going to be way tall
and the reigns tack on another run an
rbi single for taylor walls
his second run banned it in
so six runs and 70 pitches in two and
two thirds that's an awful lot for a
young arm that the royals will be
relying on all year
santana is out on strikes he tried to
hold up and for mcclanahan that's
strikeout number four
the 2-2 pitch on its way from mcclanahan
swinging in a miss
he
struck him out there's two gone
here in the fourth
long to see hits it out to kier meyer in
center field and that will
retire the side
yeah so far so good for the home team as
kier meyer will lead things off and
here's a swing and a live drive down the
right field line that's going to get
down for a base hit so there goes the
offer caremeyer took a hard turn
at first but wisely stays there and the
kk
breaks it over 16 with a single to start
this fourth
in the raise with runners at the corners
and nobody out
skies it to right solaire's going to
come in
set up to make the catch and kirmar
going to tag and head to the plate he's
going to score
kk scores on the sac fly by randy
rosarina and the rays take a seven
nothing lead bases are loaded with rays
and here's austin meadows he's already
halfway to the cycle aces loaded one out
oh and two in the pitch and a slider
bounce to the left side shortstop has a
modesty over the second one on the first
that's two
six four three double play
jake junis gets out of the jam and now
gives way to michael walker here as we
go to the sixth looks like we've got a
little tandem start going on here
mclanahan for five we'll see what we get
out of waka here on for the eighth time
and the royals have a base runner and
o'hern batting in santana's spot the
two-hole he's up there right now and
he'll swing at the first one hit it high
in the air deep to right field right
fielder phillips looking up and that
ball's gone
it's a two-run homer
for ryan o'hearn his third of the year
and the royals are on the board now down
gerard dyson pitch hitting bloops one to
shallow left austin meadows into his
right and he makes the catch and the
royals swinging at everything like
they're ready to get out of town race
have a five run lead but a long ball
here by the big fella ryan o'hearn and
you got a whole new ball game now the
pitch grounded right side could be two
brandon low has it goes to second out
turn back to first is a double play
they get it gets dyson to second and now
kelvin gutierrez is coming up the royals
aren't done yet the o2 pitch on the way
swing into this he struck him out
oh two to solaire
ground ball shortstop
and the throw to first balls to joy
ray's win it
it's a 7-2 final
and the rays
win the series taking two out of three
from kansas city